[Musique]
ils sont influenceurs youtubeurs
créateur de contenu leur terrain de jeu
les réseaux sociaux où ils sont suivis
par des centaines de milliers de
personnes voire des millions on parle
aujourd'hui dans avoir 20 ans de ces
nouvelles idoles des jeunes et des moins
jeunes quand la vie privée devient
public quelles sont les opportunités et
qu'elles sont les dérives du système des
influenceurs et pourquoi aimons-nous
tant les suivre on va discuter de ces
questions avec Michael Stora bonjour
bonjour vous êtes psychologue vous êtes
psychanalyste expert dans les pratiques
numériques fondateurs de l'Observatoire
des mondes numériques en sciences
humaines et auteur de ce livre réseau
associé qui a été publié chez Larousse
en 2021 à côté de vous bonjour Myriam
roche bonjour vous êtes fondatrice du
média les gens d'Internet un média qui
est spécialisé sur ce domaine de
l'influence également sur ce plateau
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Marie true
bonjour bonjour vous êtes étudiante en
école de commerce vous avez 23 ans vous
allez pouvoir nous veut dire comment
vous utilisez les réseaux sociaux puis
aussi comment vous en méfiez aussi
puisque d'ailleurs vous êtes
actuellement en stage dans une
entreprise qui travaille sur la
réputation et sur la question de
l'opinion sur Internet et enfin avec
nous I'm Levy bonjour bonjour vous avez
26 ans vous êtes créateur de contenu
votre compte Instagram est suivi par
près de 100000 personnes et je disais
qu'il y a de tout dans l'influence vous
êtes hypnotiseur et formateur en hypnose
exactement une petite question à
curiosité c'est pas banal est-ce qu'il y
a une mode est-ce qu'il y a une
popularité particulière de l'hypnose sur
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que vous êtes
un peu seul sur votre créneau à de plus
en plus parce que forcément alors moi ça
fait 11 ans que je fais ça et là de plus
en plus ouais il y a de plus en plus
hypnotiseur vu qu'on apprend l'hypnose
un peu à tout le monde et qui se lancent
sur les réseaux et ça commence à prendre
en ce moment dernièrement justement là
ça va faire deux ans et plus en plus
hypnotiseur sur Internet et vous avez
commencé vous l'avez dit il y a 11 ans
vous étiez adolescents il y a une
dizaine
comment c'est devenu un métier pour vous
à la base j'ai pas commencé enfin il y a
11 ans j'ai commencé l'hypnose deux ans
plus tard j'ai commencé les réseaux au
début c'était juste une passion donc je
crée des vidéos je les présentais
je l'ai posté sur Youtube et puis
rapidement
au bout de quelques années ça a commencé
à prendre et c'est surtout depuis Tik
Tok depuis le format court que là ça a
commencé à exploser et que j'ai pu
vraiment faire un métier que j'ai pu
trouver des clients pour les former à
l'hypnose c'est que c'est un truc qui
m'a toujours intéressé à te former les
gens à l'hypnose alors on va continuer à
comprendre le fonctionnement des
nouveaux métiers des influenceurs on va
notamment plonger dans le quotidien de
deux influenceurs l'une et plutôt
militante l'autre se passionne pour la
littérature et tous deux partages
quotidiennement leurs aventures avec
leurs abonnés Cécile qui s'ouvre à se
leur portrait
dont la rue Anissa passe un kognito
pourtant à 23 ans c'est une star des
réseaux sociaux avec 900 000 abonnés sur
son compte Tik Tok et 135 000 sur
Instagram elle parle depuis deux ans aux
jeunes de sujets engagés il faut savoir
que en France chaque année environ 160
000 enfants sont victimes d'agressement
sexuel c'est-à-dire que l'on compte 6,7
millions de victimes de l'ancêtre les
premières vidéos franchement il y avait
tout c'était beaucoup beaucoup de vidéos
assez beaucoup humoristiques en vrai
assez drôle assez joyeux assez fort
juste moi dans la vie de tous les jours
quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait des gens qui
recevaient toute cette joie toutes qui
avaient une certaine en tout cas un
intérêt autour de ma personne autour des
sujets dont je parlais je me suis dit
mais autant en faire quelque chose de
plutôt sérieux et qui puisse servir l'an
dernier Anissa choisi de provisoirement
quitter les bancs de la fac pour se
consacrer à ce nouveau métier elle a
intégré une agence d'influence qui lui
dégote des contrats elle dit aujourd'hui
bien gagner sa vie ça c'est particulier
parce que je fais pas par exemple ce
qu'on imagine dans l'influence des des
ventes de produits etc pas du tout c'est
je suis plutôt payée pour parler
finalement ça va être payé pour parler
sur des tableaux ronds donc c'est
beaucoup d'interventions ça va être par
exemple prendre la parole sur tel ou tel
sujet pour telle marque a choisi un
autre modèle économique
Jules comme César sur le réseau sociaux
a d'abord créé il y a 4 ans son média le
crayon avec deux associés puis à
développer son propre compte Instagram
et ce livre il a vraiment changé ma
perception de l'Algérie ça faisait
partie d'une stratégie un peu plus
globale de développement de l'image
qu'on avait en tant que fondateur de
l'entreprise le crayon et de mon média
j'avais envie de partager sur les
réseaux sociaux des thèmes qui moi
m'importait essayer de redonner le goût
de la lecture à une génération qui a
grandi avec les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui ces recommandations
littéraires font des milliers de vues
il a plus de 120 000 abonnés et se fait
débaucher par les entreprises pour
assurer leur communication une
rémunération supplémentaire et une
notoriété nouvelle salut
ce jour-là il rencontre Dana fan de ses
vidéos c'est de la richesse et de la
culture et ça faisait trop plaisir en
fait d'apprendre des choses
de comprendre ce que la personne a pu
trouver dans ce contenu Anissa aussi a
toujours été très proche de sa
communauté certains membres sont même
devenus des amis depuis le début ouais
début quoi
je me suis dit qu'elle était plus âgée
elle avait plus d'expérience et qu'elle
pouvait vraiment me conseiller sur des
petits trucs de ma vie vraiment à ces
personnel à qui je faisais pas forcément
parler à d'autres gens aujourd'hui
Anissa ne peut plus répondre aux
messages qu'elle reçoit comme avant car
ils sont devenus trop nombreux elle
réalise aussi tout juste qu'elle a une
certaine notoriété
Myriam Myriam roche qu'est-ce qui
explique aujourd'hui le succès de ces
influenceurs de sa producteur de contenu
là en l'occurrence on va peut-être faire
la différence on va s'en expliquer dans
cette émission mais on le voit il y a
peut-être une dimension d'identification
qui est très importante exactement comme
on vient tout juste de le voir avec la
dernière abonnée elle s'est identifiée à
la créatrice de contenu qu'elle a
qu'elle suit parce que soit elle a elle
comprend ses valeurs elle allait les
mêmes elle est elle habite peut-être la
même ville ou elle adore peut-être la
même passion les mêmes passions etc donc
il y a ce phénomène d'identification
peut-être que Michael pour en parler
mieux que moi mais dans un premier temps
c'est on suit une personne parce que on
arrive à comprendre ce qu'elle peut
vivre on arrive à comprendre ces
contraintes par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a beaucoup de de mère de
famille ou de père de famille qui sont
ultra suivies notamment par d'autres
familles parce que bah ils parlent de du
quotidien d'avoir un enfant en bas âge
d'avoir des adolescents etc et donc ce
phénomène d'identification fait qu'on a
envie de voir on a envie de continuer
tous les jours de regarder leur story
leur contenu pour essayer de comprendre
comment mieux faire ou pour se rassurer
aussi d'un côté en disant ah oui moi
aussi je rencontre les mêmes
problématiques oui professionnalisme
obligent pour préparer cette émission je
suis allé voir pas mal d'influenceurs et
donc j'ai découvert pas mal de
quotidiens de j'ai vu tous les comptes
maman parfaite j'ai compris que j'étais
aussi passionné par les tutos coiffure
enfin bon bref mais il y en a pour tout
le monde il y en a pour tout le monde
aime faut dire aussi que votre
communauté elle vous ressemble à vous
parce que vous faites quand même quelque
chose de bien particulier de bien
spécifique l'hypnose je pense pas non il
doit y avoir une petite partie qui me
ressemble il y a une petite partie mon
audience parmi tous les gens qui me
suivent qui sont aussi hypnotiseurs et
je pense que la grande majorité il me
suffit plutôt par curiosité et surtout
et je pense que c'est le cas de la
majorité des créateurs au bout d'un
moment on arrive à comprendre ce qui
marche à force de créer des vidéos
et les créateurs pour moi c'est des
créateurs de contenu aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux même je pense à l'époque mais
aujourd'hui c'est encore plus important
d'être expert là dedans dans un truc
particulier c'est connaître les biais
humains ce qui va arrêter les gens sur
les réseaux et c'est là que ça vous aide
d'être enfin parce que c'est le même
fonctionnement avec l'hypnose en fait
comprendre les biais humains pour
pouvoir peut-être un peu contrôler
l'esprit de quelqu'un exactement alors
sur les réseaux c'est différent parce
que le contexte va être différent et il
y a des gens qui vont extrêmement bien
comprendre ce contexte le contexte du
réseau social Tik Tok par exemple où on
swipe en permanence et le cerveau un
petit peu déconnecté on est dans cette
espèce de système de compulsion vidéo
par vidéo vidéo par vidéo il y a des
gens qui naturellement et j'en ai
rencontré c'est assez rare qui
naturellement comprennent l'état dans
lequel se trouve les gens quand ils sont
sur les réseaux et donc qui comprennent
tout de suite quand une vidéo va
fonctionner ou pas
il y a des gens qui sont assez mauvais
comme moi par exemple je suis assez
mauvais là dedans et j'ai dû
paritération à force de reproduire des
vidéos mais dire ok là le début ce début
là c'est un truc qui fonctionne etc
choper des indices comme ça pour
améliorer ensuite l'efficacité de mes
vidéos parce que une voilà une vidéo que
je vais considérer comme une bonne vidéo
sera pas forcément une vidéo qui va
fonctionner sur sur les réseaux oui une
vidéo qui fonctionne sur les réseaux
c'est une vidéo qui qui est une forme
d'addiction quoi qui fait que on a
vraiment envie d'aller jusqu'au bout de
continuer à regarder c'est ça exactement
qui va créer des attentes et donc les
gens vont la regarder jusqu'au bout je
peux donner un exemple oui par exemple
une demi-heure vidéo qui a très bien
fonctionné sur notamment en termes
d'abonnement c'est parce que j'explique
que c'est une rupture du pattern
sandwich au poulet
c'est une rupture du pattern vous avez
pas compris pourquoi j'ai descendu
j'étais rien compris
ça a arrêté l'attention de tout le monde
et du coup il soit bon ils sont
il m'a eu il m'a fait une rupture du
pattern en fait on est rupture de
pattern c'est quand il y a un mouvement
automatique quelque chose d'assez
automatique on est en train de faire par
exemple m'écouter parler et d'un seul
coup je dis quelque chose d'incohérent
où je fais quelque chose d'incent qui
vient
de la complètement cassé en fait les les
attentes et donc les gens sont restés
comme ça devant leur écran et ce simple
truc une rupture du baptême par exemple
c'est un truc qu'on peut utiliser dans
les vidéos justement pour que les gens
continuent à regarder pour faire passer
beaucoup mieux un message etc il y en a
plein sur TikTok mais c'est une
technique parmi des centaines qu'on peut
utiliser c'est intéressant Michael Sora
ce qu'on a un peu il y a des choses
différentes là qu'on vient de dire il y
a une part d'identification lorsque on
regarde la vidéo d'un influenceur et
puis on voit aussi qu'il y a tout plein
de trucs pour et bien pouvoir un peu
nous enchaîner à une vidéo ça va
chercher assez loin dans la psychologie
des internautes oui bah là on sait bien
on rentre dans le détail un petit peu
des techniques et je ne sais même pas
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il y a des écoles
qui expliquent ces techniques ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il y a des techniques
entre autres
enseigner aux États-Unis de captation de
la tension c'est-à-dire comment faire
pour que les gens restent le plus
longtemps entre autres sur une vidéo et
d'une manière globale même sur les
réseaux sociaux je pensais que le
nouveau modèle économique c'est
justement l'économie de l'attention mais
c'est évident que finalement on se rend
compte avec les influenceurs que ce qui
paraît finalement une continuité assez
logique c'est à dire que peut-être plus
ma génération nous avions un rapport
d'identification à certaines stars des
chanteurs etc on voulait être comme mais
c'était très vertical on était fan alors
il y a des fans d'influenceurs mais on
était c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait ce
rapport où c'était une atteignable et je
pense que en effet Internet est venu
créer une forme d'horizontalité dans le
rapport à toutes les personnalités les
médecins tout le monde est commenté
critiquer etc et finalement
l'influenceur est rentré dans cette idée
puisque la plupart des influenceurs ont
commencé à se filmer dans leur chambre
et donc ça crée un processus
d'identification en miroir mais parfois
très idéalisant parce qu'on le voit on a
envie d'être comme elle mais c'est
accessible on peut la commenter on peut
la liker on peut lui écrire peut-être
qu'elle répondra ou pas en général au
bout d'un certain moment il répond plus
mais c'est vrai que tout ça va engendrer
cette forme d'identification qui fait
qu'on a envie d'être comme et avec des
dérives diales au fait que il y a
parfois de la culpabilité de ne pas
arriver à être comme mais je dirais
qu'en effet c'est là où pour moi Rahim
nous fait du de la création de contenu
et là on est dans un processus de
création et c'est très très différent
même si certains sont meilleurs que
d'autres oui vous faites la différence
on en parlait entre les influenceurs
peut-être dont l'unique matière c'est
leur vie privée en direct liens avec la
télé-réalité par exemple en surfant sur
une forme de notoriété et le fait de
créer des contenus c'est ce qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs la même dans notre reportage
des gens qui parlent pour l'un
littérature l'autre beaucoup santé
mentale d'ailleurs qui partagent leurs
expériences leurs vécu c'est personnel
mais c'est presque des un travail
journalistique ou de médias ce qu'ils
font il y a une frontière qui est légère
je sais pas je connais pas bien la
première influenceurs qu'on a
influenceuse pardon qu'on a vu
mais dès qu'on commence à parler de soi
on est dans justement le lifestyle c'est
un piège aussi c'est à dire qu'en même
temps c'est normal parce qu'on veut
s'identifier à mais néanmoins la
question de se dire qu'on joue à un rôle
mais au bout d'un moment on voit que
certains influenceurs qui ont d'ailleurs
beaucoup de succès
n'ont plus vraiment de distance entre
leur vie privée leur moi réelle et le
moi virtuel le mois virtuel prenant une
telle ampleur mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu paumant et je tendance à penser
que ceux qui font de la création de
contenu ce sont des créateurs d'une
manière globale c'est beaucoup plus de
boulot disons les choses c'est un vrai
grand travail de montage de mixage et
compagnie et ça n'a rien à voir et et on
voit d'ailleurs des talents incroyables
qui parfois perce au-delà de la des
réseaux sociaux donc des talents qui
font
des contenus des vidéos qui ont aussi
des petits titres des petits trucs donc
pour rendre les vidéos plus la victime
en quelque sorte Marie comment est-ce
que vous vous utilisez les réseaux
sociaux c'est quelque chose auquel vous
êtes sensible vous le savez que vous
êtes voilà en train d'être un peu happé
par une vidéo on en a quand même tous
conscience quand on a repassé autant de
temps parfois à surfer sur les réseaux
totalement je plaide coupable et je
pense un peu comme tout le monde ici
j'utilise les réseaux sociaux oui
surtout Instagram on va dire vraiment
pour le côté justement lifestyle
divertissement et là on peut vraiment
choisir à qui on s'abonne mais
maintenant Instagram c'est aussi
beaucoup de vidéos pour soi comme on dit
ou sur Tik Tok pour toi donc en fait on
continue soit épais et puis l'algorithme
est étant ce qu'il est il vous propose
que vous avez envie de regarder si
parfois il tente je sais pas une vidéo
qui pourrait potentiellement plaire puis
peut-être que j'y serai pas aller
naturellement et puis bah oui et ça ça
m'intéresse et je voudrais rebondir avec
ce qui avait été dit juste avant ou on
sait pas forcément en fait justement
comment fonctionne cet algorithme donc
on teste dans la création de contenu ou
de vidéos ou quoi que ce soit donc vous
vous savez pas en tant qu'influenceur
créateur de contenu comment ça
fonctionne l'algorithme mais nous non
plus en fait on est on est tous acteurs
d'un d'un jeu on joue comme ça forcément
les règles du jeu ou pas forcément donc
il y a cet aspect là aussi ou on a aussi
envie d'apprendre un peu plus sur
comment est-ce qu'on est nous une
personne dans dans ses réseaux alors on
va continuer à se poser la question de
de l'influence et de savoir aussi
pourquoi et ben aujourd'hui il y a un
certain nombre de personnes qui essaient
de se lancer dans ce nouveau métier pour
ça on va rejoindre Mégane bégay bonjour
vous aimez partager des vidéos de vos
passions sur Tik Tok sur Instagram alors
justement on parlait lifestyle vous êtes
passé vous du lifestyle à la moto vous
voulez montrer quoi qu'on peut être une
une bikeuse stylée
ouais c'est un petit peu ça en fait oui
j'ai commencé les réseaux avec plus du
lifestyle et j'avais beaucoup de femmes
qui me suivaient mais ça n'augmentait
pas tellement après c'était pas
forcément mon but mais un jour je suis
passé à la moto j'ai fait une vidéo et
j'ai eu beaucoup de critiques d'hommes
en disant qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là
celle-là enfin elle a rien à faire dans
la moto et en fait au lieu d'arrêter je
me suis dit ben raison de plus pour
prouver que on peut être une fille et
faire faire des trucs de garçons on va
dire et oui du coup c'est quoi votre
communauté c'est une communauté plutôt
masculine effectivement bah maintenant
oui ça a changé du tout au tout d'un
coup je me retrouve avec beaucoup plus
d'hommes maintenant j'ai presque 70%
d'hommes alors qu'avant c'était très
équitable et du coup oui enfin au début
c'était mal accueilli et maintenant bah
beaucoup d'hommes me suivent pour la
passion de la moto justement vous vous
dites au début ça a été plutôt mal
accueilli quel est le type de
commentaire auquel vous avez eu à faire
face
j'ai eu des commentaires du style
elle fait ça juste pour se montrer elle
a rien à faire là la moto c'est pas pour
les filles enfin des trucs un peu bêtes
mais des trucs aussi du genre par
exemple des fois j'ai enlevé ma veste de
moto pour faire une vidéo et on me
disait que je faisais exprès de me
montrer mon corps pour pour avoir des
abonnés alors que pas du tout enfin
c'était juste parce que je suis à côté
de la moto et je suis pas obligé d'avoir
l'équipement toujours sur mes vidéos et
tout le temps on disait qu'en fait je
montrais mon corps pour avoir des
abonnés qu'est-ce que ça a créé chez
vous le fait d'avoir ce type de
commentaire vous avez laissé glisser ça
ça peut vous atteindre
qu'est-ce qu'elle rapporte vous avez eu
avec ça
ça dépend en fait la manière dont c'est
dit quand c'est juste juste tu montes
ton corps des trucs comme ça je m'en
fous un peu à vrai dire au contraire
quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait des filles
aussi commentait qu'il disait pour une
fois qu'on a quelqu'un qui fait de la
moto et qui montre un peu notre passion
et qui nous représente en fait les
filles ont un peu aidé et après ça
dépend j'ai eu des commentaires vraiment
plus difficile j'ai même eu mon compte
Instagram qui a été signalé plusieurs
fois et même bloqué à cause de
commentaires haineux ou même des
insultes et tout ça et du coup bah ça
c'est plus difficile alors maintenant je
vais supprimer tout au fur et à mesure
dès qu'il y a un message méchant enfin
il reste même pas 10 secondes quoi je
suis hyper alerte et je supprime du coup
ça a dû être compliqué quand même vous
avez même dit que vous parfois vous vous
autocensurez sur ce que vous voulez dire
dans vos vidéos vous vous appréhendez
déjà les réactions de certains dans
votre communauté
oui exactement je réfléchis à chaque
phrase que je mets alors que la plupart
des choses que je m'étais c'était
surtout pour de l'humour par exemple
sur où je me moquais justement des
garçons qui disaient que c'était pas
pour les filles et sauf que je me suis
retrouvée bloquée parce que j'avais du
coup une attitude haineuse envers les
hommes sur les réseaux sociaux on peut
pas du tout enfin c'était pas du tout
mon but mais forcément vu que je faisais
des blagues pour les contrées ben en
fait même les blagues l'algorithme pas
et on m'a supprimé mes vidéos donc je
fais attention à chaque phrase
maintenant c'est pas facile et malgré
tout vous avez envie de développer votre
communauté vous avez envie d'en faire un
business vous avez envie que ça reste
voilà une activité
parallèle à ce que vous pouvez faire
dans la vie
dans la vie je travaille déjà un peu
d'une certaine manière aussi sur sur
Internet puisque je fais du design
personnellement mais sinon je veux
développer ça au début je savais pas
trop ce que je voulais en faire mais
peut-être pas en faire un métier mais
continuer à montrer que les femmes aussi
on peut faire des trucs cool et en fait
récemment j'ai eu des petits
partenariats par exemple dans le monde
de la moto où j'ai pu aller voir des
courses de moto et des choses comme ça
en fait je me suis dit bah j'ai trop
envie de développer ça pour voir encore
plus le monde professionnel de la moto
et peut-être pas en faire un business
vraiment mais oui avoir ma voix qui
compte dans ce monde là je trouve c'est
important merci merci beaucoup Mégane
d'avoir passé ce moment avec nous et
nous avoir raconté ben voilà peut-être
les débuts de de votre activité
d'influenceuse
Haïm vous aussi vous avez des haters
vous aussi vous avez des personnes qui
sont très désagréables odieux vis-à-vis
de votre activité sur les réseaux
évidemment après ça fait partie du jeu
soit c'est qui a payé pour être quand on
a autant d'abonnés c'est vraiment le
prix à payer l'exemple que je trouvais
ça intéressant c'est imaginez un village
de 1000 personnes déjà dans ces 1000
personnes il y aura forcément une
personne ou deux ou trois qui seront
déjà un petit peu folles
imaginez maintenant 700000 personnes
c'est colossal quoi et donc forcément il
y a beaucoup plus de gens qui vont faire
des trucs vraiment des fois très
étranges qui vont être écrites il faut
aussi savoir qu'il y a beaucoup de très
jeunes sur les réseaux et aussi que je
fais l'hypnose donc forcément il y a
plein de gens qui pensent que c'est faux
il y a plein de gens qui pensent que
voilà vu que c'est impressionnant vu que
c'est étrange qu'on mette par exemple
des gens par terre dans la rue bah
forcément enfin pour les mettre en
hypnose par terre dans la rue ils vont
pouvoir
et comment ça va très souvent comment
vous réagissez à ça vous dites souvent
les les influenceurs les créateurs de
contenu c'est un milieu assez solitaire
enfin on se sent assez seul quand on
fait ça en tout cas cette activité très
souvent la plupart des créateurs se sont
super seuls c'est un point hyper
intéressant effectivement et il faut pas
hésiter à se regrouper en fait quand on
est créateur à trouver des gens qui nous
ressemblent c'est plus c'est hyper
important
Michael sera la haine sur les réseaux
sociaux on le voit ça peut arriver très
vite dès qu'on dit un mot de travers qui
est mal interprété on a beaucoup parlé
bien sûr du harcèlement scolaire c'est
ces dernières semaines mais bon bah
c'est la même chose aussi lorsqu'on fait
de l'influence les commentaires on est
dans un relatif à anonymat quand on
commente aussi c'est ce qui explique
cette méchanceté cette haine oui
évidemment l'homme est un loup pour
l'homme comme disait hop la méchanceté
et c'est vrai qu'on voit à quel point
les gens à l'abri du regard de l'autre
derrière leur écran et peut-être aussi à
de certaines instances que nous
psychanalystes on va appeler le surmoi
qui fait qu'on aille une forme
d'hypocrisie sociale normale qui nous
permet de communiquer fait que les gens
se lâchent il y a un déversement de
haine les haters qui sont différents des
trolls mais les haters ont toujours
existé depuis le début d'internet et on
voit bien comment finalement se retrouve
selon ce que l'on fait si on est
créateurs de contenu très souvent les
gens vont attaquer le contenu et bon on
va dire et certains peuvent avoir des
critiques intéressantes je pense c'est
toujours intéressant on le voit chez
certains par contre lorsqu'on est dans
le lifestyle en dessert que la personne
est attaquée sur sa Calais le contenu
physiquement ses origines on l'a vu avec
les nations qui a été qui a subi un
déversement et elle a d'autant plus mal
pris parce qu'elle m'aime
prend ce risque d'être dans une position
très narcissique c'est-à-dire c'est moi
c'est mon physique c'est ce que je suis
c'est ma personnalité et on voit bien
comment ils sont plus fragilisés et plus
dommageables psychologique bien sûr
parce que lorsqu'on se on prend le
risque de s'exposer on prend toujours le
risque d'être critique sauf qu'on voit
comment peut-être ceux qui sont dans
l'Internet réalité donc
le vive avec beaucoup plus de
difficultés voire même s'effondre ou
décident même d'arrêter et sur ce point
je voudrais juste rebondir on a vu Jules
tout à l'heure et j'en avais parlé une
fois aussi avec lui il demande aussi ou
en tout cas il voudrait le reportage
demander à ce que les utilisateurs
soient également peut-être mieux formés
à l'impact de leur de leur commentaire
sur les réseaux sociaux on en parlait
tout à l'heure aussi le créateur de
contenu est parfois seul mais parfois
recevoir dans une journée tous ces
commentaires négatifs ça peut aussi pas
mal joué sur sa santé mentale et c'est
des sujets dont on parle petit à petit
de plus en plus je sais pas le
harcèlement à l'école
de processus la loi influenceur qui est
passée qui a été voté le 9 juin dernier
pour encadrer ce secteur là mais il
faudrait peut-être aussi penser à aller
plus loin sur certains sur certains
points on va en parler bien sûr des
systèmes
tu voudrais qu'on choisit un instant un
peu sur sur le secteur que ça représente
parce qu'on a entendu Mégane par exemple
qui nous disait bon ben je peux avoir
des haters etc mais j'ai quand même
envie de de me lancer là-dedans on a
entendu Jules on a entendu Anissa pour
qui c'est quand même devenu un vrai
métier Myriam comment ça marche comment
est-ce qu'on se rémunère quand on
commence à fonctionne
la rémunération dans ce secteur avant de
vous donner les précisions je tiens
juste à dire que le secteur il est pas
tout nouveau comme on pourrait le croire
ça fait bien une quinzaine d'années
qu'en France vous avez des créateurs de
contenu qui qui vivent de la de contenu
sur les réseaux sociaux ça a commencé
par les blogs ça a suivi sur Instagram
YouTube etc aujourd'hui il y a
énormément de manières de de monétiser
son contenu sur les réseaux sociaux il y
a évidemment les partenariats avec des
marques que les créateurs peuvent nouer
pour partager leur avis sur un produit
partagé une expérience vous avez des
plateformes de la publicité de la
publicité exactement vous avez des
plateformes comme youtube où il est
possible de monétiser ses vidéos passer
un certain nombre d'abonnés ou c'est
pareil en postant et suivant le nombre
de vues enregistrées dans une vidéo
YouTube donne une rémunération et vous
avez aussi des créateurs qui à côté
développent d'autres entreprises encore
une fois Jules qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
à un média à côté donc une entreprise à
côté des
tuer aussi hypnotiseur tu fais de la
formation à côté donc il y a la création
de contenu mais il y a aussi une
activité qui est développée à côté qui
est peut-être plus rémunératrice que ce
qui peut ce qui peut être fait en ligne
oui c'est votre cas effectivement vous
vous servez plutôt de votre audience
pour pouvoir ensuite développer vos
formations comment est-ce que vous vous
rémunérer
95% de ma rémunération c'est les
formations exactement c'est derrière je
forme des professionnels des thérapeutes
des des psychologues qui veulent
apprendre les méthodes d'hypnose rapide
parce que moi ce à quoi que je forme
pour leur cabinet thérapie etc c'est
comme ça que je mérite les réseaux c'est
plutôt une vitrine pour vous c'est plus
ouais un moyen d'acquisition si on
voudrait parler en termes
c'est ça justement en école de commerce
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire tout ça ce
nouveau secteur qu'on voit émerger vous
comprenez qu'on puisse lancer là-dedans
on va d'autant que vous vous travaillez
aussi dans dans ce domaine là je peux
comprendre qu'au début il y a une
passion et donc on est envie de partager
ça passion par exemple moi je suis des
influenceurs qui ou des créateurs de
contenu on va encore je pense rediscuter
sur les termes qui qui partagent les
bons plans je sais pas les restaurants
sur Paris ou quoi que ce soit et
là-dessus bah ouais c'est trop bien on
est vraiment envie de savoir quels sont
quels sont les bonnes adresses sur la
capitale et ensuite je peux comprendre
aussi que après cette passion en vue
aussi bah de de du public qu'il y a de
l'intérêt des marques aussi à
fut un temps aussi à présenter un petit
peu leurs produits mais sans que ce soit
vraiment clair il y a quelques années
encore on pouvait pas percevoir que la
marque avait été directement associée
à une vidéo ou à une création de contenu
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus clair
donc je peux comprendre en effet et on
voit un vrai changement maintenant sur
toutes les stories surtout les postes
c'est vraiment écrit publicité rémunérer
en partenariat produits offert je sais
pas quelles sont toutes les différentes
possibilités là-dessus donc on voit
qu'il y a plus de transport
et je pense que c'est vraiment c'est le
modèle et comme ça aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de mal à ça c'est beaucoup plus
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
transparent et donc plus appréciable
aussi je pense dans la dans la
l'utilisation qu'on fait du réseau
Myriam bouquet avait décidé de lancer un
média vraiment consacré à ce sujet quand
est-ce que vous dit vous êtes dit que
vraiment il y avait quelque chose à
faire là-dessus qui avait un écosystème
qui était intéressant de de décrypter
etc
je pense que c'est arrivé pendant le
confinement on a vu éclore un nouveau
réseau social Tik Tok et apparaît de
nouveaux créateurs de contenu ou on sait
tout de suite poser la question de
savoir qu'est-ce que ce nouveau réseau
social comment l'utiliser pourquoi il y
a autant d'utilisateurs qui regardent
des vidéos qui s'abonnent à des
créateurs à des personnes etc et puis
évidemment tout ce qui est venu en suite
avec le texte de loi le tous les
questionnements autour de l'utilisation
des réseaux sociaux par les plus jeunes
de l'impact que ça peut avoir également
sur leur évolution sur les discussions
sur les échanges qu'on peut avoir etc
donc je sentais en fait sans vraiment le
sentir mais j'avais vraiment
l'impression qu'il y avait une réelle
industrie qui fallait analyser qu'il
fallait mettre en avant pour mieux
comprendre comment elle se déroulait
parce que effectivement jusqu'à présent
le partenariat on savait que les
influenceurs pouvaient en faire que les
créateurs de contenus pouvaient en faire
mais comment est-ce que ça se passe
véritablement pourquoi il y a des
agences pourquoi il y a des agences
spécialisées dans le talent management
d'autres qui accompagnent des marques
c'était quand même assez flou tout cet
écosystème et donc l'idée c'est de le
rendre moins flou pour que tout le monde
comprenne a parlé du covid à l'instant
sur l'explosion des réseaux sociaux oui
c'est aussi pour ça selon vous qu'on a
eu
de ce moment où toute notre vie à la
maison
et ben c'est centré sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est notre seul fenêtre sur le
monde et oui
concrètement c'était on a vu l'explosion
évidemment des pratiques des réseaux
sociaux et d'ailleurs être là où c'était
amusant c'est que c'était pas que les
ados mais c'était aussi les parents les
grands-parents voire même sur Tik Tok je
me souviens de vidéo faite en famille et
je trouvais ça très sympa parce qu'en
fin de compte enfin par rapport à cette
question diabolique des écrans bah là il
s'était possible de le partager mais on
a vu aussi dans l'après coup la chute
totale même d'un point de vue économique
puisque meta qui voulait lancer son
métaverse a complètement fait marche
arrière et on voit que certains réseaux
sociaux ont imaginé que le monde que le
bonheur numérique elle est l'emporter
sur le bonheur réel et heureusement que
non heureusement que malheureusement moi
je le réel est revenu à sa place oui je
pense que rien ne vaut le réel il faut
que c'est c'est ces réseaux sociaux
restent servent le réel c'est pour ça
l'idée de plan des restos comme moi je
parfois je regarde des choses de
jardinage j'ai pas de jardin mais je
sais pas pourquoi ça donne envie et donc
il y a cette idée que s'il faut que ça
serve le rêve parce que sinon si le réel
sert le virtuel et le numérique nous
allons être complètement aliénés par ces
choses là même si il y a des choses très
sympas mais derrière quand même parce
que vous avez cité les réseaux sociaux
qui est mon dernier livre je montre
qu'il y a des dimensions très toxiques
je vous le dis comme ça
quand même
en gros je d'ailleurs je vise plus
particulièrement Instagram qui a eu des
effets délétères sur la santé mentale
des adolescents et des jeunes puisque au
fond certaines influenceuses très belles
avec un vous avez parlé de merde
parfaite donc ça veut dire qu'à un
moment
on a tous cette injonction d'un bonheur
affiché d'être toujours idéal d'avoir un
corps parfait à l'adolescence dans la
construction de l'image de soi au bout
d'un moment de manière très insidieuse
sa déprime mais voire même ça peut
engendrer des dépressions des
conduitaristes toutes sortes de choses
et donc c'est et ça je suis pas le seul
à le dire hein vous avez franceschogen
grande lanceuse d'alerte qui a montré
puisque c'était une ancienne directrice
qui a piqué 10000 pages pour montrer
qu'ils sont au courant de exactement de
ces questions là et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète et c'est je vais même plus
loin je pense que même sur notre santé à
nous parce que vous voyez je suis aussi
papa mais pas parfait et c'est justement
ce qui fait que je suis un humain et ben
voilà et alors c'est marrant vous disait
parce que sur Instagram il y a eu le la
tendance des mères parfaites qui était
souvent des femmes très belles exécutive
womanes avec des enfants super beaux et
heureusement des Françaises ont créé le
site des maires imparfaites et c'était
très drôle et on a besoin pourquoi
est-ce qu'on utilise autant le second
degré et l'autodérision parce que c'est
un pied de nez par rapport à cette
problématique d'idéales et je pense que
les antidotes sur les réseaux sociaux
et j'étais content avec Tik Tok parce
que Tik Tok a abordé des thématiques
comme des questions non binaire du genre
de toutes ces questions même de la
tristesse un moment vous aviez des
adolescents qui pouvaient en saint Jean
disons en faisant du playback sur des
chansons de Billie eilish exprimé donc
cette idée que un monde serait toujours
le bonheur la réussite à tout prix sans
s'en rendre compte c'est très déprimant
et c'est pour ça que heureusement il y a
des gens qui font du création de contenu
de l'humour et des choses qui sont pas
toujours très gai voilà on a parlé des
risques psychologiques donc de
l'influence et on va aussi parler bien
d'autres dérives des dérives économiques
de l'influence et d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit Myriam et bien depuis le législateur
s'en est mêler et on va parler de cette
loi avec notre journaliste Quentin
Calmet
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Tom et bonjour à
tous bonjour on va parler et bien
notamment d'un clash très célèbre
aujourd'hui dans le secteur de
l'influence c'est l'affaire Booba Magali
Berda c'était le début de tout oui c'est
ça le clash remonte à plus d'un an même
le rappeur Booba dénonce alors sur les
réseaux sociaux les abus de certains
influenceurs en fait il a lui-même été
visé par un influenceur dans une vidéo
et donc il décide de répondre et
d'épingler les pratiques de ces
influenceurs d'Instagram Tik Tok et
snapchat le magazine économique capital
c'est même demandé très sérieusement au
mois de juillet si le rappeur n'avait
pas détruit je cite le business des
influenceurs une de ces influenceuses
expliquant cet article à avoir vu fondre
ses revenus depuis un an un an et demi
effectivement elle dit je vais dire la
vérité il y a des mois j'ai gagné 35000
à 40000 euros et après les polémiques
maintenant on est à des 5000 euros
dittel dans l'article
c'est revenu ont fondu en un an il faut
dire que régulièrement ces influenceurs
faisaient la une pour des arnaques qu'il
proposait on a vu ces influenceurs
promouvoir des produits problématiques
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que il y
avait soit les arnaques sur les prix ou
alors c'était des articles complètement
défectueux le secteur n'était pas
encadré une sorte de Far West alors la
Dépêche du Midi en janvier dernier en
janvier 2003 qui parlait de 60% des
influenceurs visés par la répression des
fraudes pour des manquements dans le
respect de la réglementation sur la
publicité et les droits des
consommateurs et justement il a une qui
avait été épinglé dès 2021 c'est
l'influenceuse Nabilla on regarde un
extrait
les chéris je sais pas si vous avez déjà
entendu parler du Bitcoin genre cette
sorte de nouvelle monnaie
virtuelle et en fait je connais l'une
des filles qui travaillent avec un
trader qui sont à fond dans le Bitcoin
c'est un peu la nouvelle monnaie genre
la monnaie du futur et donc en fait je
trouve que c'est assez bien
Nabila Benattia Vergara qui a écouté
évidemment de 20.000 euros pour avoir
fait la promotion de ces produits
boursiers sur snapchat sans signaler
qu'elle était bien rémunéré pour le
faire
échappé au parlementaire cette affaire
se clash non plus et il y a donc une loi
qui a été adoptée très récemment voilà
deux députés de députés se sont emparés
du sujet au printemps pour effectivement
encadrer davantage le secteur d'ailleurs
les clashs avec Booba ont été
directement à l'origine de leur
proposition de loi ce sont ces députés
qui l'ont dit eux-mêmes le texte vise à
créer un statut une définition de ce que
c'est qu'un influenceur il était temps
on le dit depuis le début de cette
émission mais ils quand même 150 000 en
France la loi qui est aussi donne des
interdits sur certaines publicités on va
voir la liste c'est très important la
loi interdit les publicités faisant la
promotion de la chirurgie de la médecine
esthétique de certains produits
financiers on le disait avec Nabilla
également la loi interdit l'abstention
thérapeutique c'est très important
encore la nicotine ça c'est les ajouts
qui ont été fait au Sénat ou encore des
abonnements à des conseils ou à des
pronostics sportifs enfin les
influenceurs devront indiquer clairement
la mention publicité ou collaboration
commerciale sur leur compte tu proposes
promotionnelle c'est l'un des points de
la loi qui est le plus compliqué à
appliquer à l'heure qu'il est pour ses
influenceurs et 4 heures de contenu et
d'ailleurs ces influenceurs et bien ils
ont critiqué dernièrement cette loi tous
les acteurs du secteur qui était
rassemblés c'est trop compliqué on t-il
dit au gouvernement c'est le message
qu'ils ont fait passer à quelques jours
en septembre lors d'une rencontre entre
130 créateurs de contenu et le ministre
de l'Économie lors d'un événement
organisé par la Fédération
professionnels de l’influence s'appelle
Lumix viennent de s'organiser justement
à ce syndicat on a beaucoup de questions
auxquelles on n'a pas forcément de
réponse à par exemple insister maril
Lopez alias enjoyPhoenix qui compte 6,3
millions d'abonnés sur Instagram le
gouvernement de son côté a promis vous
le voyez de clarifier la loi et même de
mettre en place un groupe de travail sur
le sujet Bruno Le Maire a même dit à ses
influenceurs vous êtes une force
économique majeure de notre pays il a
dit il faut impérativement que l'on
corrige le tir à propos de cette
proposition de loi il y a même promis
une prochaine rencontre avec ces
influenceurs dans les six mois à table
merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes
ces explications et nous sommes
également en visio avec Amel gaker qui
est sénatrice Union centriste du
Pas-de-Calais qui vient d'être réélu qui
est rapporteur de ce texte qui a encadré
l'activité des influenceurs Amelia
d'abord votre réaction à ces propos de
Bruno Le Maire qui promet donc de
clarifier la loi qui dit que si cette
loi est source de complexité il va
falloir la changer et que c'est à ce
moment-là une mauvaise voix
alors j'ai pas entendu dire bonjour à
tous pardon pour commencer moi je n'ai
pas entendu dans ces propos que cette
loi était mauvaise ce que j'ai entendu
c'est qu'elle nécessitait peut-être de
la clarification ce que je dis surtout
c'est que cette loi et vous l'avez très
bien rappelé où vous avez évoqué assez
précisément son contenu compte tenu donc
quand même assez clair elle visait elle
avait une vertu quand même et son ciel
qui était vraiment d'encadrer un secteur
le secteur de l'influence commerciale
qui aujourd'hui en plein développement
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas nouveau l'une
des personnes présentes sur le plateau
l'a dit tout à l'heure ça fait
maintenant bien plus de 10 ans que le
secteur de l'influence commerciale en
tout cas existe mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il est vraiment il se
développe de façon exponentielle donc le
statut ou la définition en tout cas de
ce secteur là n'existait pas
juridiquement donc nous lorsque avec les
députés de la porte et végétale lorsque
nous avons travaillé sur le texte nous
savions qu'il s'agissait d'une première
pierre à l'é existe une première pierre
essentielle et j'étais heureuse
d'entendre également une de vos invités
qui disait que on avait déjà aujourd'hui
je dirais des conséquences assez
positives puisque nous l'état d'esprit
en tout cas dans lequel nous en tant que
rapporteur j'ai souhaité travailler avec
mes collègues sur ce texte c'était
c'était de clarifier mais aussi de faire
preuve de pédagogie parce que des règles
il en existait déjà sur des règles en
termes de promotion en termes de
publicité des biens et services sauf que
beaucoup aujourd'hui d'influenceurs ne
les connaissaient pas tout simplement
donc c'est pédagogie et puis
transparence et ça c'est aussi un
élément qui nous paraissait essentiel
avec plusieurs éléments dont la mention
publicitaire collaboration commerciale
ce qui était loin loin d'être existant à
qui alors j'entends bien que peut-être
dans la mise en pratique dans la mise en
place cela est compliqué mais à
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a vraiment
l'avant et l'après de cette loi
certainement encore des choses à
travailler mais encore une fois dans le
contexte de développement de le secteur
est là aujourd'hui vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'avantages amelga car restez
avec nous on va aussi faire réagir nos
invités sur ce plateau Myriam rochefou
dites aussi un que la loi elle était
elle est nécessaire mais vous constatez
qu'il y a quand même des flous
donnez-nous quelques exemples sur
lesquels vous estimez que cette loi pour
l'instant elle n'est elle n'est pas
suffisante alors il y a des flous sur le
côté gifting quand on est créateur de
contenu on a l'habitude de recevoir des
produits gratuitement quand une marque
sort un nouveau je sais pas un nouveau
fond de teint un nouvel appareil photo
etc dans la loi il est précisé que ce
gifting aujourd'hui va falloir le
déclarer aux impôts le problème c'est
que les créateurs de compte comme ça
mais ce qui paraît logique mais les
créateurs de contenu ne le font ne l'ont
jamais fait jusqu'à présent et ont
quelques soucis sur comment est-ce qu'on
va devoir déclarer ces produits offerts
sachant que on n'a pas forcément accès
aux prix on sait pas combien ça coûte
réellement de se les procurer et surtout
la question c'était
[Musique]
je vais vérifier d'un produit ça peut
être vérifié mais le le le le le la
problématique c'est par exemple quand
ils sont invités en voyage souvent ils
sont invités par des marques à découvrir
un produit à l'étranger ou à partir en
voyage quelques jours une semaine etc
sur le côté voyage la marque ne leur
précise jamais combien véritablement ce
voyage leur coûte alors qu'aujourd'hui
quand ils acceptent ce type de
partenariat aujourd'hui il va falloir
qu'ils le déclare qui déclare sous
gifting donc il y a ce côté qui était
assez flou et dans comme votre collègue
l'a dit tout à l'heure à la Réunion lumi
qui avait aussi des comptables qui
étaient présents et qui disait que au
niveau comptabilité il y avait aussi des
zones de flou savoir comment faire
véritablement
est-ce que comment vous vous réagissez à
cette loi est-ce que c'était une une
bonne chose elle était elle était
nécessaire ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'elle a un peu stigmatisée aussi
peut-être votre votre activité qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé je pense que
l'idée est très bonne en soi enfin je
pense que c'est même important de le
faire après c'est pas étonnant que ce
soit compliqué de réformer ce genre de
choses parce que c'est deux mondes qui
communiquent absolument pas entre eux
c'est très souvent des gens qui
travaillent dans des bureaux et qui
regardent peut-être la télévision etc
ils connaissent absolument pas le métier
de créateur de contenu d'influenceurs et
donc forcément il va falloir communiquer
ça va prendre du temps enfin ça me
paraît pas je trouve ça assez normal en
fait que ça prenne autant de temps
normalement
des choses tous les cas peuvent pas être
prévenu non plus c'est normal j'ai
l'impression que c'est une communication
en tout cas on verra d'ici 6 mois donc
c'est assez bon signe tant que les gens
communiquent je pense que c'est bon
signe Amel gaker j'en reviens à vous
est-ce que c'est partir en
particulièrement compliqué pardon pour
un parlementaire de légiférer sur un
secteur vous l'avez dit il y a quand
même une dizaine d'années mais qui reste
quand même récent et puis qui est très
mouvant aussi dans ces pratiques
alors c'est compliqué et ça vient d'être
très justement dit c'est vraiment un
secteur qui bien sûr qui explose mais
qui aussi extrêmement
différent dans sa nature aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on parle d'influenceurs vous avez
parlé de 150 000 influenceurs on a
seulement 15 % d'influenceurs qui le
font à temps plein le reste ce sont des
influenceurs qui peuvent le faire de
façon parfois très périodique dans des
secteurs très diverses dans le secteur
en effet de la finance dans le secteur
de la santé dans le secteur donc oui
c'est un secteur extrêmement large en
pleine mutation véritablement donc oui
c'est complexe mais nous législateur
vous savez dans la façon dont on
travaille sur les textes on le fait pas
seul loin de là et on le fait pas dans
des bureaux c'est les auditions on les a
vu d'ailleurs
et dans des auditions moi j'ai reçu j'ai
invité vous savez parler de de Booba et
de Magali Bernard on m'a posé la
question de savoir si c'était important
que je la rencontre ou pas eu égard tout
ce qui se disait etc mais moi
aujourd'hui mon rôle c'était d'écouter
tout le monde donc j'ai invité tout le
monde ma galiberda a répondu à
l'invitation on a écouté j'ai invité
Booba qui a décliné l'invitation ce que
je respecte complètement mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on le fait à partir
évidemment d'audition dans tous les
secteurs également l'unique exactement
qu'on a reçu également donc oui c'est
complexe parce que ça reste des domaines
dans voilà encore une fois qui évolue
très vite qui sont très larges mais sur
lequel on peut à aujourd'hui et c'est ce
qu'on a réussi à faire en tout cas poser
un cadre qui forcément sera évolutif et
heureusement qu'il sera évolutif et oui
oui c'est très rassurant de savoir que
et c'est l'état d'esprit encore une fois
dans lequel nous sommes il continuera
évoluer à s'adapter et aujourd'hui je
suis persuadée qu'il y a des questions
ou des sujets qui n'ont pas été intégrés
dans cette loi mais qui vont l'être très
très vite donc il faut vraiment rester
agile et puis et puis vraiment rester en
lien en effet avec ceux qui pratiquent
cette activité commerciale
Marie on vient de parler à l'instant de
ce clash Booba Magali Verda toute cette
chasse aux influ voleur qui a été lancée
parce que vous c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui vous a permis de découvrir à
ce moment-là les dérives qu'elle impacte
ça a eu vous sur votre consommation
peut-être des réseaux sociaux premier
vous en avez déjà confiance premier
point j'aimerais vraiment peut-être
rappeler où je pense qu'on est plutôt
d'accord là-dessus que c'est vraiment
une minorité là vraiment les infus
voleurs les pratiques commerciales
complètement fallacieuses et illicite
c'est vraiment une minorité et en fait
on s'est beaucoup concentré là dessus
donc on a eu un peu tendance j'ai
l'impression en tout cas dans mon de mon
point de vue en tant que consommatrice
de contenu que tout le monde
était mauvais personne ne faisait les
choses correctement mais il y avait
juste en fait un vide juridique et
législatif qu'il fallait venir remplir
et donc mon premier point deuxième point
j'ai jamais vraiment
ce genre de contenu mais on les voyait
dans tous les cas on le voyait on se
doutait enfin je veux dire ça sent pas
très bon quand même des fois il y a
certaines recommandations aux promotions
qui sont pas les plus on va dire les
plus vous n'étiez pas je n'étais pas
naïve et mais je pense enfin je peux
tout à fait comprendre qu'on puisse
vouloir acheter un produit quelqu'un
vous le recommande justement il y a
aussi cette aspect d'affect bah vous
êtes fan de cette personne elle vous le
recommande très souvent en plus il y a
une mise en situation ah j'ai j'utilise
tel produit je sais pas ça a du
maquillage ils vont le mettre hop on se
filme regardez il y a un super beau je
sais pas un super beau résultat ah bah
oui bah bien évidemment qu'on a envie
d'acheter dans ce projet aussi puisque
la personne va utiliser ça va pas être
une pub à la télé la pub à la télé on
sait que c'est de la pub pertinemment il
va y avoir des retouches il y a la photo
il y a la caméra il y a le maquillage
sur les réseaux sociaux justement on est
généralement le présupposé c'est le
postulat c'est que on est sur une base
de de vérité parce que les réseaux
sociaux il y a pas de filtre aujourd'hui
il y en a mais donc aussi dans le le
discours qu'on peut avoir on pourrait en
effet tomber là-dedans on va dire une
toute dernière question Amel gaker
est-ce que ce qui manque aussi dans dans
le contexte de cette loi ce sont les les
gendarmes pour pourchasser les voleurs
les effectifs pour pouvoir et bien
effectivement chasser les personnes qui
qui font des infractions à la loi
alors ça a été ça a été relevé dans le
texte ça a vraiment fait partie des
débats au Sénat également d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée nationale
c'était d'évoquer la notion de moyen il
y a deux choses la première et je
rejoins madame qui vient de s'exprimer
là-dessus c'est de surtout pas mettre
tout le monde a dans le même panier et
cette loi la couverture de protéger
autant les influenceurs commerciaux que
les consommateurs ça je le rappelle
parce que c'est vraiment dans cet état
d'esprit là qu'on engageait mais ça veut
dire aussi derrière et bien durcir entre
guillemets le régime de sanctions pour
ceux qui ne respecteraient pas les
règles donc cette petite minorité qui ne
respecterait pas les règles donc durcir
les sanctions oui mais avec quels moyens
donc forcément c'est un sujet que nous
avons mis sur la table notamment dans le
cadre de la DGCCRF aujourd'hui qui est
compétente en la matière donc toutes les
autorités et compétentes en la matière
donc oui ça a été évoqué et l'engagement
qui avait été pris d'ailleurs par par
madame la ministre était de d'évoquer ce
sujet là également dans le projet de loi
de finances qui sera présenté en
novembre sur lequel on abordera aussi
cette question moyen parce que oui des
obligations c'est bien mais si on n'a
pas les moyens pour le contrôler ce
n'est pas possible et bien merci
beaucoup merci Amel gaka d'avoir
participé à cette émission Michael Stora
il nous reste vraiment quelques minutes
la question c'est aussi de savoir s'il
faut pas aller plus loin dans cette loi
quelle autre public il faut protéger
est-ce que il faut notamment accorder
une attention particulière et ben je
pense au public jeune aux ados aux
enfants vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure non mais je trouve vraiment et
en effet ça rejoint cette idée dès qu'on
met des lois sur finalement une illusion
d'expression libre c'est un peu comme ça
que proposer Internet et finalement on
se rend compte que finalement la liberté
n'existe que parce qu'il y a un cadre
c'est assez banal et donc l'idée de
créer petit à petit des cadres permet
justement de ne pas rentrer dans cette
sorte de faussemblant qui en effet à la
télé c'est clair il y a la pub et puis
on sait que c'est de la pub et en même
temps il y a des pubs qui sont
incroyablement bonnes et donc c'est la
question c'est comment est-ce que sur
internet des personnes des influx
voleurs comme vous dites il y en a peu
mais elles ont souvent énormément
d'abonnés c'est ça la question et on
sait que souvent les abonnés et souvent
leurs abonnés sont très jeunes
je sais pas jusqu'à quel âge on est
jeune mais néanmoins jeunes et parfois
d'eau ou enfant et donc ça c'est vrai
que là l'idée de mettre une loi permet
pour celui qui regarde de se dire tiens
ah oui ça c'est donc c'est faux mais en
même temps celle qu'il présente donc il
y a un rapport symbolique que je trouve
très beau très sain et je pense que même
pour les influenceurs c'est intéressant
aussi parce que au-delà de leur modèle
économique ça leur permet de dire ok
donc là c'est un rôle que je joue
et donc à partir de ce moment-là je ne
suis pas simplement cette sorte de
personnage hybride ou à force de se
filmer tout le temps parce que parfois
il faut poster énormément de vidéos les
personnes ne savent plus trop ce qu'il
en est de leur réalité leur moi interne
et je suis parfois inquiet de la santé
mentale aussi des influenceurs de
certains influenceurs parce que d'après
moi ils peuvent faire des burn out on
l'a vu c'est à dire qu'à force de
développer une sorte de moi virtuelle
impressionnant
ou le modèle économique n'était pas
toujours très clair ben parfois le mois
réel peut s'effondrer sort de tension
comme ça ce qu'on appelle nous en
psychologie le fosself le fossel d'un
acteur d'un chanteur on sait parce qu'il
joue dans un cadre précis mais
l'influenceur lui c'est tout le temps au
quotidien
aussi Myriam là-dessus parce que vous
aussi vous dites qu'il faut quand même
aussi notamment protéger sans doute les
plus jeunes et que c'est là-dessus qui
est encore un chantier à faire d'un
point de vue législatif effectivement je
pense qu'il y a aussi un besoin de
formation auprès des plus jeunes pour
peut-être leur expliquer comment
utiliser les réseaux sociaux ce qu'on
peut y trouver qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire collaboration commerciale sur une
story des créateurs de contenu parce que
nous avec le recul qu'on a on peut
comprendre mais quelqu'un qui est
peut-être beaucoup plus jeune n'a pas la
même logique et la même réflexion que
nous aime les vies le mot de la fin
comment vous allez capter notre
attention jusqu'à la fin ah là j'ai pas
d'idée pour la fin c'est une rupture de
pattern je vous ai bien appris du coup
j'apprends
vite 32 minutes ça m'a suffit merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission on va
retrouver très vite pour un nouveau
numéro d'avoir 20 ans
[Musique]